und ihn mit der hand hatte ihn gerade
mit der hand gekillt alter moment eher
der typ hatte keine waffen hat ihn
gewartet
services kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge hacker show heute
zeige ich euch wie immer die besten drei
hacker die mir in der letzten woche
zugeschickt wurden ich hab mir letztens
in einem video gefragt was ihr eine
hacker show verändern würde weil ich
gern oder feedback mit einbauen will von
ihr meint vor allen dingen dass ich mal
die hacker ende reihenfolge bringen soll
also der erste hacker ist sogar der
zweite bisschen krasser und der dritte
dann richtig krass also wir haben jetzt
eine abstufung ansteigend eine abstufung
ansteigende an stufen wir quasi das von
nummer eins bis nummer drei die 30 kite
und das heck level gepflegt irgendwas
rum anna kratzer werden
doch wie immer gilt wenn ihr dabei sein
wollt material auf youtube hochladen um
gelistete mit den link entweder per
youtube schicken oder per e mail die
alte e mail gilt nicht mehr die wurde
gesperrt warum auch immer
die neue e mail es in der beschreibung
und nicht vergessen aber wohl dazu
lassen jeden sonntag neue hacker schon
ok dann lasst uns aber erstmal loslegen
die einsendung stammt von trololo lp
rolle unterstrich rp so hier geht es
wieder los
er hat das selbst kommentiert quasi als
wären ja ich wollte seinen namen nicht
sagen aber man sieht ihn halt doch
relativ deutlich
der domino effekt aber wiederum die
richter
doch der alte herr otto lukat oder ok
alles klar scheint nur noch berg fleck
alter beschreibt es ja noch richtig
mutig sei der gute mann glaube ich ja
schon felix ja ich habe deine luft da
kommen schon ist es halt schon dreist
man jetzt geht es rund
es ist halt schon 30 dann bei auch pvp
mitten in die luft zu stellen aber ihr
kennt sich auf diesen moment wenn jemand
als ich einfach so sagt ich schwebe
einfach vier blöcke über den boden und
jetzt 300 blöcke das ist halt schon so
ein bisschen bisschen pause aber was
bringt es denn zu hauen
warum zensiert der kommentar oder [ __ ]
warum hat die junge grazien inventar
zensiert hätte es macht keinen sinn wenn
ihr wisst warum der sein inventar zu
sechs wochen
wie man das ist ja nicht zufällig hatte
das bewussten weichzeichner drüber
gelegt okay aber jetzt verstehe er wie
gar nichts in diesem video jörg pag
folgen
es ist noch beck also die no no schlag
tüte alles klar dies am start
gut dachte ich mir erst okay dass
flächen lag er gut dein fleisch hack ist
ja zu sagen ich finde es dreist ist es
einfach das hier sich so viel mehr wie
blöcke über den boden in die luft zu
stellen die leute zu boxen so jeder
schaut ein an
man wird garantiert worte brachten so
was wenn versucht irgendwie zu
vertuschen wegzufliegen aber ändern wenn
der neustart der station komplett am
aber gut ab zur nächsten sendung
diese 1 sendung stammt von group gaming
tv und sie heißt hacker escape league
bkf dws bäume jetzt mal nicht welche
heck drankommt weil eventuell können sie
ja lustig werden pass mal auf ihrem
acker rein sagt so kämpfen wir alles
die damp league alles gut er sieht dass
er verpackt und dann war
dreiste einfach weg fliegt so bitten wir
mal genau in dem moment aufnimmt kommt
schon bruder er fliegt einfach direkt
wieder hoch als aber so ein richtiger
pazifist einfach geld kein bock auf
stress coaching fliegt ihr einfach ins
heck werden will
es bleibt jetzt ist er wieder weg
vielleicht hat auch noch extrem noch
beck unterhalt zur schwebebahn kommt
runter und gut aber jetzt aber in
hannover verloren
witten hat ja sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
da und liegt jetzt runter weil die zeit
vorbei ist airdrop sich aber der maid
von dem anderen gaming pad oder wo
geworden es ist halt schon crazy alter
guck mal hier
von diesem moment wir waren einfach
gegen einen kämpft als das auto so
sachte hat keinen bock mehr fliegt
einfach weg dazu bei die bozner dann
auch befindet entstanden aber ich mag
die einstellung ehrlich gesagt dass das
richtige so einfach stress aus dem weg
gehen wenn jemand einen stein schwert
endlich bauen will dann fix hat einfach
weg so ist es auch im echten leben und
bla bla bla bla bla bla männer fakt so
hecken hat er gar nichts gebracht suche
ist eine sammlung stammt von kevin und
er schreibt hacker auf timo ja wir schon
direkt mal rein oder lang zu quatschen
das ist wohl ein gewisses tun wenn ihr
so einander stehen okay was ist jetzt
der hack in der runde sieht alles gut
aus
warum aber es geht weiter es geht weiter
der kurs hat den gerade gewonnen
das kind hat einfach nur eine full die
rüstung und angel wie kann die in one
hätten de facto es kann stärke trank
oder sowas moment ja okay jetzt frisst
eine böse combo richtig nass gemacht
verwenden sehr schön
jetzt tue wie warhol was uns schon
wieder normaler fahrt also was man sich
vielleicht erklären könnte ist das der
übrigen stärke trank in der
der thriller drehen ist in dem quiz und
stärke trank aber dass hier verschiedene
kits oder kitty mit der hand hat er ihn
gerade mit der hand gekillt alter moment
eher der typ hatte keine waffen erhalten
hat ihn gewonnen hätte
hohoho alter kummer hat keine waffe oder
ein kind in einer hand what the [ __ ] und
er hatte vor live schauen aber darauf
auch kabinette hier wieder mal seinen
chef bisschen kleiner machen können hier
alter schwede mit der hand also leute
moment mal entweder bin ich jetzt
komplett blind und es im wohn stärke
truck drin
aber nein es sei es mit der hand da okay
den instant nochmal hier wir gucken uns
um einen zweiten clip an ich kann mir
das nicht erklären könnte sein dass er
irgendwie / kill eingegeben hatten dass
sie klug geschnitten hat aber niemals es
macht keinen sinn und kompetent
rechtlich gute kommt und dann einfach
ein hit und s down
ich verstehe es einfach gerade überhaupt
nicht wie immer wenn ihrem plan davon ab
was das ist ich hab noch nie von einem
one hit killer heck gehört ich gesagt
jetzt mit der hand hat ihn getötet
womit wir gucken mal einen chat im
internet müsst ihr stehen ob sie bei
sich selbst getötet hat oder ob bursting
kampf gegen verloren
dein gegner hatten okay also steht
nichts davon dass irgendwo mal wurde
passwort ich weiß nicht mehr leute ich
verstehe ich die welt nicht mehr warten
wie z wann kann man leute mit einem
schlag töten es kann sein theoretisch
dass er wesley spielern gegeben hat also
vorausgesetzt der befehl geht auf die
moral was jetzt gerade nicht weiß wer
sein und hat es dann an kluge karte
nachdem der andere ihm mitgegeben hat
aber warum sollte man so was machen es
sieht nicht danach aus als hätte der
andere gewinn heck mit dem mit einem
schlag getötet hat weil in dem kit waren
keine stärke tränke drin war doch eine
zweite runde gesehen
also hat er jetzt einen 123 runden in
saint gekillt das sind immer die
gleichen geht's also für die ecenta
alles klar also dass nichts drin vor dir
angel und ein schwert ja und jetzt sag
einfach instant gekillt in der 1
auch in runde zwei genauso jetzt richtig
3 ist auf 103 mit der hand sogar also
bin ich wirklich gespannt was eure
erklärung dafür ist ich habe keinen plan
ich bin auch jetzt raus ich habe genug
für heute leute immer lass gern daumen
nach oben da war ich das gefallen hat
einen kommentar unten mit weiteren
verbesserung tipps zu hacker schauen das
war's aber von mir wünschen noch einen
schönen sonntag oder wann auch immer
etwas wie ihr seht bis dann haut rein
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten sonntag
mit der nächsten folge hätte